[Music]
it's michelle phan lab muffin beauty
science chemistry PhD and cosmetic
science nerd the other day I came across
this video from five minute magic called
25 things about cosmetics you never know
never knew it talks about things you'd
never know about cosmetics and when I
was watching it the explanations were
kind of off so I thought I'd give an
explanation based on actual science of
how why these things are happening if
you like nerding out about Beauty make
sure you click the like subscribe to my
channel and click the notification bell
so you don't miss any videos ok so let's
get started alright so first of all
fruit is not human skin they do a lot of
stuff on fruit and while it looks cool
it just isn't really the same
you
you
so firstly the stuff you're cleaning out
of pores with poor strips is not Church
it is mostly dead skin cells and oil
which has slowly started oxidizing which
is why it starts looking dark sometimes
these are called sebaceous filaments but
they don't really have a proper
technical name these can turn into black
heads if they solidify and clog up your
pores but using pore cleansing strips
isn't a very effective way of getting
rid of them because they'll just fill up
again really quickly poor strips
probably aren't as bad as a lot of
people make them out to be but they're
not a very effective way of dealing with
these it's much more effective to use a
leave on product to keep your pores
clear rather than going in and evicting
them forcibly after they have there some
good ingredients for this are salicylic
acid and benzoyl peroxide
you
I want to know what makeup remover oil
they're using because that is awful
I have never had a makeup remover oil
not at least smudge my makeup there's a
lot of variation in what's in a makeup
remover oil but in general oils dissolve
oils because they're both nonpolar so
I'm actually quite surprised that this
happened
so either the makeup remover oil is
absolutely terrible which i think is
probably the case or it's simply the
fact that fruit is not human skin I'm
not really sure what they're trying to
show here foundations are emotions and
the outer phase is often called the base
so if you have something watery on the
outside then it's going to dissolve well
in water because water mixes with water
with the oil-based one it's going to
repel the water and so it doesn't mix as
well so that's what we're seeing here
okay I have no idea how that is the
logical conclusion of that experiment
I'm not sure how that shows that it's
clogging pores so things that are oily
aren't always comedogenic so for example
mineral oil and petrol items they are
not very comedogenic and I feel like I
probably don't need to tell you if
you've been watching my channel but skin
doesn't need to breathe and makeup
doesn't stop skin from breathing
you
is actually the lower layer of the skin
on my skin model it is this section it
doesn't lose its moisture very easily it
is part of your flesh
it is about 70% water the bit that does
lose moisture is usually the stratum
corneum which is the top layers of the
epidermis which is all the way up the
top up here when an apple goes Brown it
is not losing its moisture what's
happening is that it's a reaction
between enzymes and the fruit and oxygen
in the air I think that they're using a
really thickest layer of Vaseline here
it is much thicker than you would ever
apply to your skin they are correct in
saying that Vaseline is good at sealing
in moisture it is the best occlusive
amongst all our common skin care
ingredients
you
what okay so vitamins agen Kate they are
good for your skin they are oil soluble
vitamins vitamin A especially is where
we get our rationale it's from but
vitamins have nothing to do with
cleansing your skin and it has nothing
to do with why these apricots are
plumping up out of the different oils
olive oil is somewhat polar which means
it prefers water compared to baby oil
which I think is why it's going into the
water base apricot a lot of the time
when you're seeing these rehydration
demonstrations what's happening is water
is going back into the fruit and so I
think that's why the olive oil is doing
this after four hours but not the other
oils I have no idea what the cosmetic
aisle is I assume it's going to be
something that's quite a non-polar
possibly mineral oil which is what baby
oil is I guarantee you if you mix a tiny
amount of these four vitamins into the
baby oil it will not plump up your
apricot I don't know why you're trying
to plump up apricots in the first place
but if you do I will eat a plumped up
apricot if that happens
you
all right so shampoos contains so
factors which help dirt dissolve
unfortunately they can also help dye
dissolve which is why in both of the
versions with shampoo there is some dye
coming out eggs do contain a tiny amount
of surfactant but compared to the
shampoo it is not cleaning dirt off so
really what this is showing is that eggs
are not good shampoo this is just a
collection of demonstrations with
statements after them that has nothing
to do with the demonstration so hair
products don't all just work by
absorbing oil dry shampoo absorbs oil
and I think that's about it conditioners
coat your hair hair spray solidifies on
your hair so that it stays in place and
I think that's what this is showing the
scissors are scraping off some
accumulated product on the hair probably
also snapping off a whole bunch of
cuticle which is not great fun fact your
cuticle is actually transparent so if
you scrape off cuticle it's going to
look transparent like it does there it
won't be the color of your hair just
don't scrape your hair like that that's
not good for your hair
you
you
you
they need better waterproof eyeliner I
have sweated through some of my
waterproof eyeliners I have done in
turns exercise for hours and it has not
budge so makeup fixing sprays do work by
putting on a waterproof film over your
face that holds your makeup in place
which is similar to what the hairspray
is doing here the difference between a
hairspray and a makeup fixing spray is
that usually makeup fixing sprays let
designs to be a bit more flexible so
that it's less uncomfortable it doesn't
feel like you have a film on your face
that is a pretty unrealistic amount of
spraying maybe you'd use this if you're
going under some hot lights if you're
doing some theater performances but I
think for everyday life it's probably
not going to be that nice if you want to
learn more about how makeup setting
sprays work I have a video on this I'll
link it in the description
[Music]
you
this is actually a really nice
demonstration the brown paper test is a
legitimate test for lipids which
includes oils there is a lot of
variation in different foundation
formulas but in general for dry skin
they do tend to put more oil in to
replace the oil that's missing from your
skin okay this is not a great idea
pigments that are safe for your eyes are
not the same pigments that I say for
your lips and the reason is we do tend
to eat some of the pigments that we
place on our lips your eyes are not good
at absorbing products that you put on
them most of the time things are flowing
out of your eyes rather than into your
eyes but your mouth is made for eating
things so there are some pigments that
are okay for your eyes that are banned
for products on your lips an interesting
fact is that the Egyptians used to use
lots of heavy metal pigments on their
eyes and that wasn't actually why they
got heavy metal poisoning from eye
makeup it was actually because they
would lick the brush that they used and
then apply the pigment to their eyes so
any remaining pigment on the brush would
end up eaten
maybe one day I'm hoping that you will
be mine
[Music]
so this is sort of a legitimate DIY
version of what's actually in your eye
makeup products carbon black is a
pigment that you find a lot when you
have a black product and you can make it
from burning organic matter like the tip
of a banana I don't know why they picked
a banana they could have burnt anything
carbon black can be an inhalation risk
though but I think in terms of safety
this is probably not as significant a
risk as things that you would encounter
in everyday life anyway like being
around a campfire or burning your food
or burning a candle I do think it is a
bit of a pain though it does seem a lot
easier to just buy a true dollar
eyeliner owner
[Music]
Oh No
[Music]
don't do it okay that's not as bad as I
expected I have seen recommendations for
the worst things to put into mascaras
spit do not put spit in contact lens
solution don't put it in a lot of people
assume that because contact lens
solution has a preservative then it's
fine to add it to something like mascara
the problem is when you're mixing stuff
into it it changes what your system is
and so your preservative might not stand
up to that anymore probably doesn't
stand up to that anymore
contact lens solution is designed to be
dropped out of the container it's not
designed to have a dirty brush go in and
out covered in mascara and so the
preservatives might not work as well
probably won't work as well water also
not that great it doesn't have
preservatives oil would probably be a
much better choice than any of those
other ones still pretty risky though I
wouldn't recommend this maybe if you
used it and then immediately use the
mascara and then chucked the mascara out
it might be reasonably safe I wouldn't
keep it there one of the scariest things
about eye makeup is that if it's not
preserved properly you can get these
really really awful infections which
were quite common before preservatives
were a big thing and makeup if you have
a strong stomach you can look up
pseudomonas corneal ulcers they are
gross
[Music]
that was an experience I feel like they
have to know how awful their videos are
it's impossible to make the sort of
video all day and not just have some
sort of awareness about this I think its
clickbait or comment bait because it's
just so obviously bad did you enjoyed
this video let me know in the comments
if you want me to do more videos like
this if you like this video give it a
thumbs up and you can subscribe to my
channel you can also follow me on lad
muffin Beauty science on Instagram and
check out my blog for more beauty
science see you next time - nerd out
more about beauty